ceci n'est pas un vrai poisson qui se ne
sont ni des crevettes ni des filets de
poisson bienvenue dans l'univers des
produits de la mer fait à base de
végétaux sauf celui ci bien sûr les
associés ont réussi à recréer pas
parfaitement mais presque la texture de
la viande le goût dans les burgers etc
on le voit les loyers et chercheur à
l'institut sur la nutrition et des
aliments fonctionnels
maintenant ce n'est pas pourquoi pas le
faire avec les poissons on connaît les
matières premières on connaît la
technique c'est de recréer une texture
c'est de recréer un goût voici un des
nombreux nouveaux restaurants vegan à
montréal ici que des sushis végétalien
offert à une clientèle diversifiée 80%
par reagan et elles sont vraiment
surpris même plus que je devrais sushis
parce qu'elles sont plus vous touria
plus s abat ses imitations de crevettes
sont à base de contacts l'ingrédient
principal de cette force anguilles et
les protéines de soya et pour créer un
immigré autant on remplace le poisson
par de la tomate mariner
au niveau de la tomate pour le ton on se
trompe pas la couleur est la même c'est
rouge la tomate contiennent
naturellement de l'acide glutamique qui
est le précurseur du goût il m'a mis des
restaurants offrent de plus en plus de
ces simili produits de la mer mais ils
se feraient lentement le chemin jusqu en
épicerie ça reste énormément des
produits de niche comparativement aux
fausses viande les faux poissons entend
encore peu parler mais ça s'en vient
la croissance est là on sait une du sang
poisson finir vg bénéfice déclaré myriam
landry et nutritionniste jeu le dessus
l'une des sources d'oméga 3
quand on mange du poisson ou des
produits de la mer souvent c'est pour la
qualité des bureaux mais est-ce qu'on a
ça dans les faux poissons et fruits de
mer
mais c'est intéressant est certaine les
produits qu'on a regardé qui utilise de
l'huile à base d'algues pour aller
justement cherché les acides gras
oméga-3 qu'on va retrouver le
typiquement dans le poisson c'est sûr
que c'est pas des nutriments qu'on va
retrouver seulement dans le poisson les
italiens peuvent très bien aller se
tourner vers des sources d'oméga 3 comme
par exemple les noix de grenoble et
graines de chia les graines de lin faire
triper devient très mobiles quand même
intéressant au niveau des fibres convoi
l'intérieur là c'est différent déjà des
jeux gourmands de jeudi quand on regarde
par exemple un faux poisson pané
c'est sûr que tout comme la production
remplace le ça va être plus riches en
gras je suis bouche bée
c'est impressionnant comme c'est
vraiment impressionnant sa salle aveugle
il y aurait plusieurs confondues
pour recréer ces produits sans protéines
animales ça prendra toutefois beaucoup
d'ingrédients on va retrouver de l'eau
en premier et en farines enrichies
protein devait textures et l'huile de
canola isolats de protéines de soya
poivrons une tonne de blé oignons verts
amidon de pomme de terre ovine
exhaustive pour pas que tout ça c'est
pas on n'a pas le choix de rajouter
certains additifs sont des émulsifiants
pour faire en sorte que tous se tiennent
meti cellulose sucre de canne
purée d'ail rossi amidon tapioca je me
rendais à la moitié de la liste
d'attenté du titre ans tellement est-ce
que des ingrédients de base qu'on
retrouve presque systématiquement dans
chacun de ces produits je retrouve
beaucoup d'ingrédients à base de soya
comme par exemple dans ces deux produits
sont maintenant un bloc de ce monde qui
semble enroulée dans une algue
c'est ici c'est vraiment comme tous un
peu rugueux le bar couleur saumon par
exemple j'ai hâte de voir à la cuisson
c'est la couleur à ronger à l'aubergine
du pain aux autres encore une fois ce
premier agréable comme texture est
vraiment pas mal
est-ce que ça goûte le saumon je
trouvais qu'elle l'oeil c'est
intéressant mais vraiment je trouve pas
ça bon je trouve pas ça me va mais c'est
vraiment plus l'estran planète qui
ressort moi je trouve le sepsis faut
fouiller mes sauts ici c'est un régime
qui se vit le sait les gimmicks savoir
de homard tu vois le premier magasin
sans blesser ni don de bataille oui ça
m'a vraiment comme si on peut dire que
c'est beau quand jacques théron jacques
s'est pas particulièrement
quelque chose qui s'avère l'audace c'est
un légume racine en fait le puits c'est
une bonne base pour faire un faux
poissons mais en même temps c'est pas
c'est pas une source de protéines les
congères quant à la crevette geste en
apparence la l'intérieur si on voit que
c'est quand même des saveurs qui se
rapproche un petit peu justement plus
les plus de saveurs marines un peu mais
c'est vraiment pas prononcé et le comme
si on mangeait quelque chose car humaine
comme du poisson du allemande écrivent
ils maintenant reste à savoir son acide
produire les quantités de protéines
varie grandement d'un produit à l'autre
par exemple pour une portion de 100 g
il y à 18 grammes de protéines dans ce
four mans et un maigre 2 grammes pour
ces simili crevettes soit dix fois moins
de protéines que les bras ça veut pas
dire que c'est pas correct de manger ces
produits là nécessairement mais il faut
supplémenté avec un petit peu plus de
protéines avec un autre aliment on aura
ajouté le que ce soit des new york que
ce soit sociale ces options vegan sont
toutefois plus intéressante d'un point
de vue environnemental que livrait
poissons et fruits de mer que dans la
tête du consommateur s'est pas encore
totalement acquis la pâte
environnemental important de la pêche de
la surpêche le fait que finalement au
niveau de l'aquaculture aussi on génère
des déchets donc c'est pas une industrie
qui est totalement la produits
environnementales intéressantes pour
quelqu'un qui ne souhaitent pas aux
cuisines et des crevettes aux vrais
poissons ça peut être les uns de recréer
un peu cette expérience le mais sans
aller chercher des poissons